Rihanna's breaking her silence about
being in an exclusive relationship with
her billionaire boyfriend and wanting
babies I look forward to all of the
pregnancy rumors after this
RiRi finally confirmed a bug she and
Hassan Jamil have been an item for quite
some time she without a doubt once kids
and has a chill life with him in London
I like to take walks cook those are my
favorite things to be here very very
basic her playful side came out talking
to Anna Wintour after ditching her Met
Ball this year and another big event is
the Super Bowl halftime show something
that you would be willing to entertain
as fashion is my first time hearing
about the Super Bowl since last Super
Bowl while confirming she refused this
year because of the NFL controversy RiRi
also seemingly shades headliners maroon
5 saying quote I just couldn't be a
sellout I couldn't be an enabler next
when speaks out after news broke
she's leaving The Voice I have a strong
opinion about things that I like and I
don't like the 50 year old was
rehearsing for her Vegas residency
yesterday with boyfriend Blake when we
learned her Sin City gig is why she's
leaving the NBC hit where they met Gwen
tells Shane she's trying to find balance
in her life that's nearly impossible
when you're a mother of three boys when
credits Blake for helping especially
after her divorce calling him one of the
greatest gifts now to fierce females
opening up about overcoming obstacles
never accept know if I'd accepted no I
would have stopped when I was 14 and
they were like no you're too tall and I
said oh but and I talked to my way in
Nicole zendaya and gwennyth are among 10
diverse ladies honored in Elle
magazine's women in Hollywood Issue
I was about 19 and I lost a movie part
to somebody else and I started to feel
like oh no girl God it isn't even that
good and my mother was like stop right
there don't ever ever disparage another
one
[Music]